al alam au rendez vous êtes prêtre vous
avez croyant donc je vais vous faire une
interview croyances
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai péché mon père j'ai bougé par
l'attribution torah de pénitence
je crois que ma fille d'offrir à une
coupe de champagne en sortant est ce que
vous croyez au diable oui bien sûr quand
je vous vois
[Applaudissements]
rak thaï et un rire sardonique rire
diabolique via verges h et pire oui aux
besoins du vergès oui c'est vrai est ce
que vous croyez que la france va gagner
l'eurovision cette année
oui évidemment parlé tout à l'heure avec
natasha st-pier ses rivaux c'est pour la
fois si vous croyez aux extraterrestres
non aux anges
oui ça existe les hanches wii auront
moins esthétiquement et poétiquement et
artistiquement et pourquoi pas sûr
naturellement vraie raison le gardien
moyen âge que je prie toujours avant de
venir une émission de télévision vrai
c'est l'ange des vanités oui jeudi
souffre le mois sur la gueule pour que
je me prenne pas trop syrien sait bien
que je ne me gonfle pas de vanité le
sait bien et l'ange gardien canadien et
que les agents cache sexe bien sûr et
des anges gardiens le mot paix je viens
de plus grand bien mais il faut que
j'explique au prince qui a des plaisirs
plus grands que ceux du chac
ah oui ah oui par un gros que tahri 3
quand il sera roi il aura besoin vous
aurez besoin d'avoir quelqu'un comme
champion andre cher bien entendu moi je
vous dit rien on voit très bien tu vois
très bien confesseur auprès d'un pouce
il a rien dit sur tous les hommes
politiques
elle a d'abord tu vas invitera après il
n'y a rien c'est clair mais y'a carlos
de bourbon 1 qui me demandent aussi des
bonbons - 6/10 fait 700 personnes tous
les soirs philippe tesson dit que c'est
un génie qu'est ce que je vous dise oui
il continue est ce que vous croyez à
l'efficacité des crèmes antirides
ça ne m'intéresse pas du tout s'il a
laissé l'occasion gérard parages ces
questionnaires la saison ouais c'est bon
vous croyez à la réincarnation à la
réincarnation non je crois la
résurrection ce qui est très différent
expliquez-nous mais la réincarnation
s'imaginer que lorsqu'on a été lent
gushue a marre oui et qu'on a pêché on
va devenir les maps aux dégradations de
plus en plus bas et qu'au contraire
quand on a été bien on va devenir
baleines et ensuite colibri couet alors
que la résurrection c'est lorsque vous
croyez il ya un raciste animalier
terrible pourquoi colibri cmuc baleine
j'ai pas dit si ces valeurs là les
lycées et la résurrection c'est très
différent c'est de croire qu'après la
mort l'amour est plus fort que la vie et
que la création est tellement belle
qu'elle remettra avec nous avec des
corps mais avec déplaisir infiniment
supérieure à 5 sur surréaction des corps
bien je ne méprise pas de sexe ah non
mais j'espère bien dit dans est ce que
vous croyez que chirac sera réélu en
2002 aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe j'espère qu'il
y aura un groupe qui se formera qui
s'appellera tout sauf chirac
un groupe de rock et à la mort paris may
à bayrou qui va se présenter a mis
d'accord c'est vrai aa c'est pas un
technocrate c'est un vrais paysans
il a fait une très belle biographie du
roi henri iv
bien entendu n'empire il a des racines
et le charisme en plus et je peux dire
qu'on n'avait pas peu dire que bayrou si
les démocrates chrétiens quand même
c'est plus votre truc quoi béchir a été
assez à ce point là quand même dit si tu
as fait chiffres bien est ce que vous
croyez à la mort d'elvis
non elvis n'est pas mort donc il ya 20 %
des américains qui pensent comme vous
mon père est ce que vous croyez au sexe
sans amour annoncé le pire qui puisse
arriver à et est ce que vous croyez à
l'amour son sexe oui je suis bien obligé
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus